and also goodbye
also known as papi shampoo from
making
porridge next to the south line
festive competition that describes bread and fruit like
dominican de swiss tweets of course if
we have two things that are different the
first one she doesn't know what we're going to
to cook today and the second is that I have
to say all this in Spanish and you don't
know any Spanish right, well if you didn't
understand anything
the recipe is Dominican we are going to make
stewed chicken but the recipe is mine it's
ready
[Music]
ready a little  little by little I understand a
little what is above
[Music]
that a little chicken chicken and a
stewed chicken were excluded yes
there is no simple palmero and not even a Dominican
said this base the first time then
we are going to get to the list yes if she is
lost
she is understanding  yes yes yes good you got
lost yes what web every day or easier
we dominicans clean the chicken
clean that's good now the
chicken is used up and grab the lemon they refuse his
girl
come
I need no n  you need so much online
about the e verify is to clean clean the
cleanest chicken as you know cleaning
like cleaning cleaning and now it
will significantly improve the hand and
clean it well your love what it needs
is love you put a lot of a lot of love
later we add the
balsamic vinegar slowly today
take it out vote what you want to see it says
everything everything everything now mix it mix it ok
don't worry it's love we're going to
start with salt south-south and pepper
pepper pepper
pepper pepper a teaspoon
[Music]
and a teaspoon of salt the best thing
is  that
never puts a teaspoon of the
nato weeks suite specialty if not a
little more a little more but you
have to do it until you know how to
increase it you have to look at it that's more with
luxury forget about recipe and pods and we're going
to add
a little more unease halves  very little more little more
around here
take take
and from spaces it's hot no no it doesn't sting a
little oregano
how nice
although yes they do turn on half a f  then
miriam fire fire
then I play
between medium and a little miriam and logically
we are now going to cut the onion
onions and red red onion
[Music]
lacking they are tiny and what
I do know is tiny I don't know if it's okay
at night and that's right  a lot of onion here they
go with the oil oil oil if you put
the oil
and put a little less with half the
onion half and half
yes
we are going to put the bullón a lyon cube
for parading sandra sisti never
until this tastes good as you want it  it's
your way of doing it
that also sounds like and also there
then I play with the other on high heat
this prize that went high after
the lid was raised although the mouth is missing and
now we are going to put the chicken today at one
how many seconds there and then we throw  the
chicken here in the pot one thing has come to me
one thing the garlic garlic buildable
like this under the internet and super
[Music]
and
nothing is the same
how delicious
and I do it like this because I like
chicken meat grab the seasoning the cold
first  grouper and then he cooked it in the pot
now the tomato sauce number
ok like 4 ounces the Dominicans we
don't use half incop freedom that pod
number if everything above
that we leave it for about 30 minutes 40
minutes 30 minutes 30 300 grimi nets
we are going to  cook the rice with pigeon peas
let's cut the white white onion
machín spanish how many when a
quarter the same
ok the same
[Laughter]
half and half
that
skips me
hahahaha if you want you can also
add it today yes although luis aceituno
puts like 4 and a little  burrito and
inside now we are going to close it
now let the water go down huanca 33 if
not down please
let's cut it into small squares
we are going to set it free
using a little bit as comfortable
it is already hot
because the rhythm smells like cilantro
we are going to put the pigeon peas at  match the
whole can although there is we are going to cover it
now we are going to rinse the rice using
the hashtag showcase pittsford we are going to
put the tomato sauce here yes
this  committee now let's go with the marinade a
teaspoon of salt
yesterday was a question if you've tried she
is criminal
girl the artist what we are going to put
a packet of seasoning action if juanpa
kitsch yummy now we are going to put a
teaspoon of salt salsa terrorists
salt and  pepper
someone king of soul in rankings
it's me being a teaspoon of oregano
we're going to add olives and olives
not
much like four or five and the juice and
now we're going to add a glass of white water
health water for a glass and a
half of soul rice  band cup rice media
ah yes yes
there they put a high game that boils and
in a lawsuit lowers the heat
is the best part of cooking and it is to
fry banana
with the oil inside the pot made in
fact and they continue without love and when your
body the  banana cut this piece
first here they are hiring they are
allowed and we Dominicans cut the
banana at an angle
angola and it is this pod I don't know what or not a
cutlery
slowly
yes
when it starts to win  a little
color and the flipper
yes it
is a katana
[Laughter]
we grab the planes after
the napkin what grabs the fat
is gray
removes all the fat
[Laughs]
as you want
and the sauce
[Music
] yummy
me  I think today they are in previous
plans
and you didn't do it in your genius way,
now
only I understand
[Laughter]
and maybe thanks
from yesterday
[Music]
and that's it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]